I kind of want to see Colleen do an
invitation of Joe you know I knew this
was gonna happen invitation new and
she's ready watch this [ __ ] are you
ready
get the panther get the panther what
does Joe do
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we
specifically have two white people here
today let's go and look over on the
white side white table white side the
white side
before we start catching up with Colleen
we have to we have to acknowledge
Steve's awesome outfit again and I feel
I was talking to him outside he's got to
show the pants otherwise you don't get
the whole well look you guys [ __ ] me
though because I thought I thought you
guys had the black light installed so
I'm like ready
no cause Anthony Anthony and Ryan you
guys are like gonna redecorate the
office right and you guys are talking a
big game about how we're gonna have the
black light on and I thought the black
guy was gonna be on today
that's only on that side that's what
this outfit's for it accentuates it's
like arcade carpet but I'm the only one
glowing yeah it's like a just your skin
just me it's like a Hot Topic poster
yeah wait Steve where did you get this
jumpsuit I got it at cry for help.com
it's a big site you have better help set
the deal with you
wait does your necklace say woo or move
no this is woo it should say ooh I paid
good money for it to say well
I didn't even realize good good money
it's custom it's custom don't worry
don't worry dude that's Iced Out yeah
that's not real though and you got
Flappy Birds on your hat can they see
your
head I don't know because you guys
didn't get the black line does the woo
cryptocurrency actually make that
necklace [ __ ] no where the [ __ ] did you
find whoa
I had custom I
just cussing like let's like literally
I'm like [ __ ] having to design this
[ __ ] on websites and print it and send
it to my he designed the color of the
zippers because I'm too [ __ ] early at
all these gem ass cryptos that I'm
buying too [ __ ] early yeah it sucks
to be earlier way too hard dude I do too
much research I gotta say that the
digital colors on the hat work with the
outfit that's what I was going for thank
you it's very good I matched it myself I
didn't even have to have to ask Nikki or
anything just as much as the fur on
Joe's chair works with Colleen that's
right that's kind of this is all planned
this is all planned it's a Vibe it's a
Dundee you should get the Dundee Vibe
it's good this is like they're like the
richest white people we've ever met yeah
hey that's not true because Shang Ching
look like a regular dude you have a
letterman jacket that's Asian now that's
ours now hey what kind of same Pantone
yeah dude are we moving on to the
catching up with Colleen part now Barbie
doesn't give a [ __ ] about fashion no I
do care let's go straight into it let's
go ahead catching up with Colleen how
you doing Colleen I'm good I'm good
that's it
that was our segment hey
[Applause]
are you satisfied yeah I'm satisfied can
we get some graphics on that too next
time we introduce that like on Colleen's
side when we say catching up the clean
[Music]
yeah that would be good so whoever's
editing cam can you please do that let's
talk about the truth Colleen's here
because Joe's gone for like a month
abandonment problems I think yeah uh
he's gone for like a month right and so
we got Colleen's sitting in here for the
next few days so she's gonna be joining
us not just replacing Joe but being her
own individual yeah I'm replacing Joe we
would like you to be more like Joe did
Joe ever do the the promoting joombie
OTR
no
so savings for on the camera
because uh so you remember uh I don't
know if you guys remember because just
click because Colleen's here so she
reminds you of June yeah no no because
Joe was like I remind him of Joe the
last time we shoot can we do it I'm
gonna open a joombie so can we do uh we
talk about it and we promo it but like
everything in this company we have great
ideas and it goes away so that's correct
I think Joe himself forgot to promote
that he's opening a jubi in Hawaii which
is I'm bringing it up now it's like a
promoter of Colleen's a spokesperson for
June B Hawaii that's why I brought it
let's bring it back to Ketchum Colleen
killer [ __ ] promo that was
honestly I was talking about that promo
that's how it's [ __ ] done that's why
this guy's been on YouTube for [ __ ] a
decade and everyone else is a goddamn
loser
that was unbelievable I was trying to
promote Joe stuff because he forgot to
promote his own [ __ ]
up
so spokesperson for June B Hawaii feel
free to uh let them know
um do you know what joombie is yeah so
um I don't even know what it is talk
about it talk about it just guess and
just commit
that's why Bart's promo is so [ __ ]
good I would guess that it's a it's a
beverage you know it yeah one for one
maybe I do know
close yeah
the most delicious beverage that you
have to go to Hawaii you're selling
you're selling it yeah you have to you
got the right outfit you have to go to
Hawaii you have to
um is it because there's no other
locations oh no there's there's actually
quite a few there's one in Vegas there's
not
they're right next to each other too
because that's really good marketing
very very deep into Circus Circus
they're competing with each other into
the same company
that's how [ __ ] hot they are right
now jumpy is the hottest thing on the
market though Circus Circus is that what
you said it was yeah June B three of
them next to each other in Circus Circus
hey the June be opening and Roland
Heights not kidding was really [ __ ]
fun we had so many people like so many
jk people came out it was really it was
actually a great time it was uh 400
people in the plaza holy [ __ ] that's wow
cool it like wrapped around all around
the plaza is pretty awesome hey jumby's
actually pretty good I like it yeah me
too I've got it being customer civilian
food honestreviews.com have you ever
like just cold had it like how come we
don't get zoomy anymore because we had
to we had to we had to fire that guy who
got his jumbee and then we had to cut
everyone's pay 40 percent
full circle yeah yeah hey what happened
to you this morning you said something
happened oh I was going for a jog and
then I had to take a [ __ ]
that's the thing that happened to you
yeah so does that happen though that's
what you wanted to share this morning
well it was kind of stressful oh what
happened so how close were you so do you
know you know from uh the brewery yeah
to so the brewery is like off the five
uh Main Street five Street uh the five
freeway and then there's a breakfast
place called Nick's Cafe oh yeah it's
nice like a big pig all right so
I was jogging and then on the and when I
was leaving the gym I was like oh dude I
gotta take a [ __ ] and then usually I'd
be like you gotta play it safe because
when you're running around who knows
what the [ __ ] gonna happen to poop I
think yeah and then so I was like ah
[ __ ] it I'll just [ __ ] uh roll the
dice so I ran as soon as I got close to
Nyx I was like oh [ __ ] I really got to
take a [ __ ] and I was just gonna run
into that bathroom and just dookie in
there yeah but I I don't know what it
came over me but I became shy like one
time in my life and I'm usually not shy
at all you didn't I did it so as I was
running back why wait why did you become
shy well maybe the bathroom wasn't good
enough he walked in he's like this
doesn't suffer I don't even get close to
it like I've been to that restaurant I
ate there before and what's crazy is
I think because I knew what was about to
come out I didn't I would rather have
gone on the railroad tracks than gone to
that bathroom I was actually looking I
was like running I'm like you know those
roller traps I'm talking about none of
that makes sense I'm like I'm just gonna
go down the railroad tracks around the
bushes and just [ __ ] go crazy but I
was like I can't make it did you maybe
think for a second because this has
happened to me I'm like if I go in there
and I'm about to fill my [ __ ] pants
up and if they're like you have to buy
something first and if I if I don't get
this [ __ ] out in time you know what I
mean like I can't [ __ ] fumble with my
wallet
oh my God like please my test is about
to come out of my lower body please I'll
get the eggs benedict please I'll pay
after I swear to God in my life but
they're like we've heard it all before
sir
you're not pulling that one on this
establishment
not again it scares me so maybe that
happened to you yeah no I just I think I
think I respect that place because I ate
there a lot I know what the bathroom
looks like you don't have to actually go
to go inside yeah it's on the back so
you can just bypass do you [ __ ] in your
own home yeah and you don't respect your
home yeah respect my home but I do
respect this place Nick's Cafe and then
I was actually I just kept I was like oh
[ __ ] I'm just gonna hold on and then I
ran straight back into the gym and good
deal of the bathrooms were open but it
was a very stressful room JK pack time
JK pack time
we don't [ __ ] in Nick's Cafe we don't
ever you understand that place is very
historical though is it it has been
there since like 1920 or something oh
now we gotta [ __ ] in it
JK boys careful boys and careful girls
don't [ __ ] in Nick's Cafe thank you
Steve we need to make a sign for that
door yeah
you know like that second amendment gun
symbol but say no cheating bro we should
say that we should take turns sitting
outside with a shotgun
this is on patrol hey you taking a [ __ ]
in there all right you better not be
taking a shot here pal yeah yeah number
one's only that's what we say not here
pal go over to Joe's go to Barbara
Brigade
restroom located at barbell Brigade
climb out the door it's like just just
follow this the squiggly line it's like
[Music]
episode is brought to you by DraftKings
NBA fans the wait is over basketball is
back so tip off the season with
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NBA new customers
can make any five dollar NBA moneyline
bet and get 200 in free bets if your
team wins check this out in addition to
the usual bets everyone can boost their
winnings up to 100 with DraftKings
stepped up same game parlays go to
draftkingsportsbook app opt-in and place
a stepped up same game parlay today with
payouts bigger than ever draftking
Sportsbook is where I go to bed on the
NBA well I'm excited to see the Lakers
you're gonna move to Vegas my heart is
here with LA of course so I'm excited to
see what the lit how the Lakers do I've
also seen in some of the preseason the
Warriors are going crazy so they're also
my Cali peeps so got a rep for my Cali
Lakers and Warriors download the
drafting Sportsbook app now use promo
code off the Record make any five dollar
bet this week I get two hundred dollars
in free bets if your team wins only at
jockeying Sportsbook with promo code off
the Record minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply so you show notes for
details but were you pretty close to
taking a [ __ ] on the railroad tracks
this is the one right I was gonna commit
yeah yeah dude it's cool all right no
[ __ ] in this establishment I was
actually committing to it ever ever what
you [ __ ] think about not even you
Nick if you work at Nick's Cafe you stop
[ __ ] right now yeah yeah there's
also enough human [ __ ] on the sidewalks
of La that you actually go like
I don't I don't think I'm embarrassed
here's another Vegas boy no there we go
it's just you're just no especially that
area he knows what I'm talking about
yeah you're just like
it's nothing new what's the ratio to
square mile of uh all right well they've
been cleaning per capita yeah they've
been cleaning it up lately oh yeah for
like once yeah since forever unrelated I
just saw the housing market in Vegas the
housing market in Vegas contracted like
a little ten percent
so it's like getting a little cheaper
out there unrelated
how long do you think it was going to be
yeah Nick not long not long not long
unrelated so we've got to buy now are
you like Pasadena until you die not
really I don't really have like a hey I
heard the Vegas Market is like 10
contracted oh
it makes a little more appetizing you
know what I mean but there's not enough
human [ __ ] in Vegas so I'm not really
like into all that I like I like to keep
it Grassroots how do you know corn of
these [ __ ] guys they talk about Vegas
anytime they can anytime they can sneak
in the conversation oh you know in Vegas
they go looking for [ __ ] in Vegas I'm
like this is the place it's got the most
this is for me I didn't say nothings
yeah whenever whenever you bring up
Vegas you never talk about human [ __ ] on
the sidewalk because there isn't it
fight fight fight so I'm staying here I
could take one yeah I'll take one
take a big one on the sidewalk have you
guys ever have you guys ever stepped in
human [ __ ] on the sidewalk uh no I can't
say I have how do you know if it's human
or adoption but yeah oh you you know
when it's here yeah what how do you
distinguish this by the location of
where it was so it sounds like you have
yeah where was it and how did you know
it was very sad because there was this
one morning where um I got to the studio
and I had to switch one of the paper
backdrops like really really quickly and
so like the client was coming like five
minutes so then I I took this paper down
and then I ran to get another one from
the car like there's one 12 foot rolls
oh yeah and then as I'm running like I
put it up I was like oh thank God the
cloud will be like two minutes and I
looked and there was just like a cartoon
track of boot [ __ ] like I stepped in it
with my [ __ ] boots and then I looked
and it was like in between the boot
teeth and it was like oh it was just
like a giant was it one of your good
boots I tracked it in it was actually I
tracked it into the through the whole
studio and how did you know it you could
see like it was like he ran on his white
cycle just smells way worse it's a
repainting fee of 300 usually [ __ ] off
the curb or against the wall oh they do
that [ __ ] where they put their back
on the wall or they they they sit
against the curb so it's always like off
the curb barely yeah and that's why I
said about it I pulled up in K-Town last
week and then right when I pulled up
onto the side of the road I saw homeless
lady taking a dump on some other dude's
car like just the car that was like
just parked and then just under a tree
there's she's just like literally in
like just like a bra and then her
[ __ ] pants around her ankle and she's
literally this is the [ __ ] back of
the car she's just looking around and
she makes eye contact with me but she
don't give a [ __ ] it's like
dude comes out he's like not again oh
[ __ ] finishes her [ __ ] pull this stuff
up that's the kind of art that I would
do as a Banksy I would do street art no
street art where people are like what
the [ __ ] is the story here like a bunch
of poop boots like going going down like
a sidewalk and then going up a wall and
people are like
guy [ __ ] walked up the wall
how the [ __ ] did he do that yeah yeah
just make people ask little questions
yeah and they actually smell it too it
is real that's real that's real it sells
for like Millions yeah you don't put
just bidding on it on the street pulling
that [ __ ] out like the like like putting
in museums and [ __ ] immersive experience
like the Shadow and Hiroshima remember
all that oh yeah the Shadows the Shadows
too that became that became like a
museum it's like a museum piece of like
like well unfortunately it was people oh
God okay I know what you're talking
about yeah they're just chilling out
they'll explain it in detail for all the
viewers okay so they were just chilling
out on the morning of August 6 1945 and
um
like there's there's one very famous one
it was like a guy who's like sitting on
some steps like this right and I'll get
my make sure to get my cool pants in
here
um and and he was holding a cane and
then the bomb went off and he gets
vaporized and all that's left is like a
like a shadow of him basically like from
all the soot of him but it's a perfect
outline of a human form on the ground on
the ground all yeah like on the in the
masonry or whatever on the on the stone
[ __ ] wild and there's there's a lot
of those throughout like Hiroshima and
Nagasaki like from those bombings so we
went from poop
all the way
to Hiroshima Hiroshima Hiroshima oh
careful that's Joe
Joe the white side's guy yes
we're all gonna just take a turn being
Joe I kind of want to see Colleen do an
imitation of Joe you know I knew this
was gonna happen invitation new and
she's ready watch this [ __ ] are you
ready
get the Panthers what does Joe do
that's it
that's pretty cool that's good that's
good that's when Bart's telling a story
and then Joe's like thinking about
somebody
where Anthony's like so this red car
crashed into the wall what color was
card game
and we're like what the [ __ ] are
you guys for 10 years come on when I
have to edit the reels I always have to
like cut away from him because he's just
going like this
I have to show something else
I'll see him stare [ __ ] miles away
dude and I just want to know like what's
he thinking
I'll be like I'll be like this red car
crashed the wall he'd be like I never
had a father
[Laughter]
that's pretty entertaining that's like
that day I was telling you guys about
anchor protocol day when I was I was
telling Joe what to do and [ __ ] and he's
like Steve never told me what to do and
I'm like Joe I probably told you what to
do 17 times and then still the day the
morning up he's like so what are we
doing
all right dude all right why don't you
just tell him man yeah just tell cheese
dude stop holding out yeah yeah a lot of
money we're talking here this is a good
opportunity to talk about uh June B in
Hawaii yeah Circle back yeah I mean
we've had some pretty good topics the
most delicious drink yeah so David so
David's also a partner with jumbi uh
which oh what did you say
[Laughter]
stuff they're doing interviews for staff
fight because they're hiring and David
told me in the middle of interviews when
they're asking the person questions
Joe's like
and then David afterwards like what the
[ __ ] are you looking at yeah
but even in the interview it's like why
are you qualified for this job
they gotta be more interesting I gotta
grab Joe's attention if they want the
job are you able to wake up early and do
this and he's like you know in Japan
she just has this accident
did you do when you did a job interviews
for barbell did you interview the people
yourself in the beginning yeah and then
what kind of stuff did you ask them one
of the funniest questions would you
rather [ __ ] your mom or your dad
it's a JK classic and there is a right
answer but you know in the beginning of
hiring you asked like very like
what you think those stereotypical
questions are supposed to be yeah
because you're not experienced right you
don't even know what you're looking for
so one of the questions we asked are
like oh what's the restraints with some
of your weaknesses and this guy goes my
weakness
my calves and I was like me too you're
like hired general manager yeah I was
like what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me is that not a good answer for
a workout place that sounds pretty good
he's disgusted by it you gotta have big
Cavs if you want to work at barbell yeah
he's opening up he's opening up You
Gotta Laugh on the inside there's no way
you're not laughing at that I know but
I'm like this guy came dressed with like
a dress shirt tucked into his slacks so
he was ready that's the kind of response
he's giving I'm like bro D think about
it for a long time because that makes it
better yeah I forgot man yeah we don't
like that quick-witted [ __ ] it's got to
be really like he's got to be thought
out always like cats
I've been working on them yeah yeah my
overhead press is pretty good yeah my
pecs no I've been working on them do you
feel like when that guy answered you
gave him a face do you like because I'm
sure that's sometimes hard like if
you're being an interviewer I can't tell
you I give faces in my very expresses I
don't think I'm expressive am I you
should probably just throw your eyebrows
yeah yeah he said Captain you're like
we're done here yeah
Bart's like okay yeah
it falls asleep
and that's why you enjoy our friends
because that's you and then Joe's like
looking over here
Joe's doing squats in the back dude mid
interview
really good really good thank you
a little bit much you haven't even been
here that much in your daily
he goes oh I know runs into that room
grabs something and it's completely
unrelated to this story but the best
part is it took four minutes and a lot
of shouting for him to produce something
that has nothing to do with any segued
from here yeah and then yeah it just
comes out with a canoe yeah
I was like Joe we don't need this no we
really don't he's like no no we really
do make the video so good it's like no
Joe we really don't need it
[ __ ]
foreign